we're learning more details and new
details tonight about what happened to
trigger air-raid sirens Thursday in Tel
Aviv and then the response to it
correspondent ray yanks fills us in from
our Middle East newsroom two rockets
fired from the hamas-controlled Gaza
Strip towards Tel Aviv were likely
launched by mistake despite that
assessment by the IDF Israel struck a
hundred different targets in Gaza as
Israeli airstrikes pounded Hamas
positions militants began firing more
rockets towards southern Israel Israel's
missile defense system the ayran dome
intercepted most of the launches and by
the time the Sun rose in the Middle East
and this round of violence appeared to
have finished Palestinians have rallied
on the border between Israel and Gaza
for nearly a year
demanding access to fuel electricity and
clean water as part of current ceasefire
understandings today was the first
Friday in 51 weeks that no
demonstrations took place along the
border but Hamas says it is prepared to
fight after this round of violence if
conflict breaks out again on the Israeli
side the past 24 hours of escalation
turned into a political debate on how to
deal with the violence from Gaza Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu has
been criticized by members of his own
cabinet who called his response
overnight quote pathetic his opponent in
the upcoming Israeli elections and his
former chief of staff Bennigan's said
Israel should not ever allow rockets to
be fired from Gaza we cannot accept any
violation of our sovereignty and our
security regardless of who did it in the
Gaza Strip whoever is Israel's next
prime minister will likely face more
rocket fire from Gaza but now with
Palestinian factions they're receiving
military support from countries like
Iran the next war in Gaza could be the
bloodiest yet
Brett train angst in Jerusalem Trey
thanks